[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
morning morning everybody maybe it's the
evening for you if you guys are in india
um maybe it's the afternoon but here in
los
angeles it is 10 45 well 10
50 in the morning welcome everybody
thank you for joining me on this live
stream we're doing it again
we've been doing it every single week
for the last year i think this is
close to the one year anniversary maybe
honestly past the one year anniversary
at this point
um but man it is good to see you guys
it is good to hang out with you all um
i'm very excited it's gonna be an
exciting stream
no audio no sound
hmm weird
okay because i'm
getting audio
one moment
can y'all hear me now
test test let's see
can you guys hear me
give me the thumbs up audio delay how
much of a delay
super lag super delay hmm
audio's just delayed
can you hear me now is this better now
dang there's audio now
delay sound late coming okay um
i have no idea
why this would be happening
three
all right i think we're gonna we're
gonna figure this out
um bear with me bear with me
okay we sh should be good now
y'all i think i just had to
i was messing with some stuff
testing testing yo let me know if it's
good
should be good
i had i was messing with the audio okay
it's fixed
now it works yeah okay guys apologies on
that um yeah i was messing with some
audio
doing some vst plugins and whatnot we're
fixed we're back to it thank you
thank you guys for joining me um you all
scared me
thank you thank you all right so back to
it y'all um
we have a lot of very fun announcements
to get into on this stream
i'm gonna be announcing the guest judges
who are going to
join me next week to go through the top
100 renders we can't
go through there's 700 submissions right
now at this point
um and if you guys don't know what i'm
talking about i'm running a cg challenge
i'm giving you guys basically a an
animation template and i'm working on
that
art right here today on the stream now
i'm gonna announce the guest judges in
probably about five minutes here i'm
right i'm not going to wait till the end
of the stream to do that to you guys
that would be horrible
but i do want to just say first how
excited i am that you guys
have participated in this challenge it's
been insane like i said there's 700 plus
submissions so far
um at five seconds each that is
just under an hour for this montage
so next week we're going to be doing the
art review
and choosing the winners the week after
that will be the montage there's going
to be two montage videos
there's going to be a top 100 montage
video and then there's going to be
everything and i'm going to be dropping
those on the same day for you guys to
just dig through it all and have a good
time with it
um like i said 700 plus submissions with
like four days left
that's like that that's an hour that is
an hour right now so it's going to be a
good time going through all that
and making sure everyone's names and
discords and um
instagrams and twitters are all correct
on that it's gonna be intense
um other than that let's see i got a
booklet here i got a booklet
with with announcements let's see okay
so let me talk to you guys about what
we're doing on this stream
all right because this is my last stream
before we
you know before we dive into um
the review the breakdown uh showing the
winners my art breakdown all that good
stuff this is the last working stream so
i want to show you guys where my art is
at right now
and what i like about it what i don't
like about it i'm gonna go ahead and
open up after effects and show you guys
what i've created over the last month
um so
let's see here i am
i have officially like maxed out c4d
this is kind of where it's at right now
this is the art this is what it's
looking like but let me open up
after effects and bring in some of these
renders to show you all
what we are looking at and where my art
has come
over the last month okay
so let me switch over to a standard view
uh workspace reset
all right so this is what we're looking
at guys
um this was the first thing that i kind
of came up with
on the first week that we did this and i
was going for something
if i pull up my pure ref file
um where i was basically going for a big
post-apocalyptic
destroyed kind of scene right
so something like this
is what i was going for and you guys
have seen in the thumbnail
um this was kind of my like my concept
art that guided me
so far and we got this and it's doing a
little like a
side scroller action here and it's
getting us to like a little uh
basically this little ravine this wash
that goes to a giant hole in the
background which is kind of difficult to
tell that there's a hole in the
background
now from there you know i kept working
on it and i got you can see here that
the detail in the foreground has been
shifted a little bit
i added a fence i added a little bit of
fog
and i actually took some photos
and made some custom textures out of
these photos in a sewer
and put them down into this little uh
this kind of hurricane wash river ravine
thing um storm drain situation and i
think on the last stream i talked about
how i did that
so from there right we're going to v3
and there's a big difference between v2
and v3 v3 i've messed with the lighting
and i've clearly added some destroyed
buildings these are some photo scans i
got on turbo squid that are just insane
um and i changed out the hdri worked on
the lighting just a little bit
and i actually switched out this hole if
i scroll forward
i switched out the hole
for a sewer because the hole wasn't
selling it didn't look like a hole so i
was like let's just make it a cave
instead basically
i added a little bit of plants down in
there um
and you know essentially
just kept adding a bit more detail v3 to
v4
is you know an even bigger difference
because i'm adding more buildings in the
background
um i change the lighting you guys can
see that the lighting is starting to
shift i'm starting to pay attention to
that
um but you know i like how there's light
bouncing off the edges of these guys but
not really here it's like a not really
happy with that situation
but the render's getting better it's
improving over time but i'm still
not happy with it at this point i'm
still not happy with it
and it wasn't until v5 that i started to
be like yes
this feels like something and v5
i've really spent time on the lighting
and i obviously switched out the
background here i completed my
background
or at least most of the background and i
really focused on the lighting i
wanted to make sure so if i scroll to
the end
both of these you can see oh this one
actually didn't make it to the end let's
let's consider this the v5
and get rid of the color correction i
have on here that doesn't look good at
all
boom all right so let's just consider
this the v5 and at the end
i'm really starting to pay attention to
the lighting like i said so i have a
sunspot coming down hitting this robot
right here um
and we're going to get into that we're
going to get into the story elements
because that's what i'm going to be
working on
on today's stream are the story elements
and i'm
i'm going to touch on that in just a
second here
but yeah look at the difference between
this this is a huge difference
i really paid attention like i said to
the lighting i wanted the sun to come
down here and illuminate the foreground
but just the strip of the foreground i
wanted the
the very foreground to be in in shadow
and behind that also in shadow and i'm
essentially doing like strips of light
that go into the background right um so
i'm going to talk to you guys about how
i did that
how exactly i'm doing that but what
we're going to get into on the stream
today
is how to take your render from what
we're looking at right here
which looks amazing like i'm very happy
with the composition
and the lighting right now i'm still
gonna tweak it a little bit but i'm like
really excited about the way this looks
but it's not enough because
we have seen time and time again the
post-apocalyptic
look you've seen it in book of eli
you've seen it in children of men
you've seen it in edge of tomorrow
you've seen it in
you know a million other movies that
look like this
and for me to be able to get this
look looking as good maybe as those
movies maybe
it looks that good i would hope so um
that's not good enough for me
i need to be able to stand out from all
the other post-apocalyptic scenes that
feel cliche
and what we're gonna do the way we're
gonna do that is
with story and style so
the last 20 you guys have heard the 80
20 rule story and style
so um 80 20 right
is the idea that uh 80 of your thing
is recognizable it's known people have
seen it before
people people tend to gravitate towards
things they know
so that's the 80 but if you know it too
much you're gonna get bored you know you
can
watch your favorite show so many times
unless you know maybe it's the office or
something
but still like you want that 20
freshness the 20 freshness is what i'm
looking for
in this render right now it's just 100
percent fine
but it needs the 20 fresh and that's
what i'm gonna do
with story and style i'm gonna see if i
can't figure that out
on this stream so um
i'm gonna let you guys know the guest
judges here in just a moment
but y'all you may have noticed that this
stream is um
is sponsored by nordvpn so i gotta give
a shout out to nordvpn guys
let me show you guys a little breakdown
and tell you a little bit about nordvpn
and then we're gonna get right into
announcing the judges
right after that and we're gonna hop
right in to making some cool art
all right so i'll see you guys in uh in
just a second
nordvpn is a service that protects your
identity on the internet by
routing your internet or ip address
through servers across the globe
nordvpn is like the energy shield that
protects master chief in battle
or say the fellowship of the ring to
frodo's journey to mordor
nordvpn protects your private
information and files from
malicious no good hacksaws but that's
just the beginning by routing your
internet through another country servers
you get access to that country's content
if we select
india all of a sudden we're getting
indian content on netflix and youtube
and i'm a pretty big gamer too and know
some of you guys are as well
so you can use nordvpn to switch regions
if you're on a very laggy server it's as
simple as that
so if you guys want to support more
videos like this in the future and get
access to nordvpn then click the link in
the description below
nordvpn.com punisher that's nordvpn.com
p-w-n-i-s-h-e-r to get 70
off your first 25 months of nordvpn
and get yourself protected
all right all right yeah so um
nordvpn is pretty sweet i do enjoy it i
think if you switch
your um uh your server to europe
you can get all the ghibli movies um
[Music]
if you switch to europe on netflix
pretty sure
that's uh that's the way to go so yeah
definitely click the link in the
description y'all
it's 70 off two years of nordvpn
it's a good freaking time um
so yeah everybody let's freaking do it
let's uh
announce these judges so
who could it be who could it
be all right y'all
so we're talking
three judges we got three judges to
announce
all right the first judge
is going to be none other than mr peter
france
the blender master himself peter france
will be joining us next
week live on the stream to go over the
top 100 renders and what we're gonna do
so actually we're gonna get together
beforehand and determine the winners
before so we know exactly where we're
going and then we're gonna we're gonna
show you guys what we got so we're gonna
look at every single one
and make sure we truly choose the top
uh the top 100 so that we can choose the
top five from that because there's just
no way we can
do all 700 plus all right so peter is
the first one who's the second one the
second one is none other than mr ren
weichmann
who will be joining us peter and wren
will be joining us
live next week on the stream to
freaking review your guys's art and
finally
oh i'm excited to tell you guys about
this i'm very excited
um guys ian hubert is going to join us
he's coming on the stream
um if you guys don't know who ian hubert
is man he just
put out his latest short film dynamo
episode one it's like 20 minutes long
and it's insane ian hubert is going to
be coming down
and he's going to be joining us next
week wren peter ian and myself
the four of us are going to be looking
at your art we're going to be breaking
it down
live next week and choosing the top five
winners
and giving you all some amazing prizes
um first place gets a full rococo
mocap suit with like the gloves and
everything
you also get a wacom tablet you get uh
aftershocks
aeropex headphones you get you know a
year of quixo
mega scans and you get some awesome pny
ssds and it just goes down from there
so guys it's going to be intense it's
going to be a very fun stream
the four of us are all good friends so
we have a really good energy together
and it's going to be a good time so
i really look forward to that all right
y'all
um let's hop into it so
um super amp for that yeah it's gonna be
good it's gonna be a really good one
next week
but yeah this week you know we are
focusing on
focusing on how to take this render to
the next level you know what i mean
it looks good but it just kind of blends
in with all the other post-apocalyptic
scenes you may have seen
and we're going to try and fix that on
the stream today so we're going to do
that with story
and style and i'm hoping that the story
elements i add to this render
can be that extra 20 freshness
that we need to really make this render
catch your eye
and i'm hoping that this 20 the 20
of story that we're using
to stand out a little bit from all the
other renders
i'm hoping that that could also be um
style points too because right now
it yeah i guess it's kind of stylized
it's a post-apocalyptic scene
but you know i do have a robot here
chillin
right in this robot um
you know this robot is uh
it's fine you know it's it's i'm
choosing to go that like sci-fi route
but
again we've seen that before we've seen
like the sci-fi post-apocalyptic thing
with like edge of tomorrow and a bunch
of other
movies and shows and ips and whatnot
so i'm looking i'm looking for ways to
to amplify that so here's what i have
right now here's the idea that's in my
head you guys know that this is
a render challenge with a character
right so we have a character
um the current setup is there like
holding something they're carrying
something
um and i'm thinking about that
element so what could they be carrying
and who is the character so here's
my thoughts what if
you essentially had a robot character it
could be a robot or it could be a human
and they're pulling you know those like
it's called a palinking it's like a
a royal box with two sticks on it
that two different people carry to carry
around the king or the queen or some
royalty person and they're in this box
so they don't have to walk around
that's a palanquin so imagine this
character carrying
a hovering palinkine a hovering little
royal box that's made of beautiful
ornate gold
so already we have a juxtaposition
between the destroyed poor
dirty dark environment and this ornate
filthy rich golden box
and in this box is a person that you
can't quite see
but you you can see their arm is hanging
out
like you rolled down your window and
your got your arm hanging out
why does the mic have a 3d sound god
dang
um i don't know
let's see desktop mic
um hmm
i spent the last couple like here's what
i'm gonna do i'll probably just
hmm
god dang y'all trying to get me to fix
this mic situation
hmm i'm gonna get it fixed next time we
do this
let me change this up real quick
is that any better i'd have no like
filters nothing on this right now so
this is just raw the raw mic
um it sounds perfect sounds good sounds
great all right let's go back to it
this is this is the difference now
someone's trolling all right we're
chilling we're good
y'all are chilling okay so
anyway back to the idea so like a rolled
down window
you have the arm hanging out of this
royal box that is hovering it's made of
gold
and it's a robot arm
with like gold rings on it and
everything and it looks like
super ornate really nice
and that image to me is really
interesting because
what happened here was there a robo war
and did the robots win
and now the robots are doing the same
thing
that the humans did to the robots like
we made robots
we made them do what we want whatever we
want when we want
and now the tide has turned so it's like
you know the terminator
situation where we go to war with the
robots but the robots win
and they force us to like carry them
around
and like work for them we're basically
slaves to these robots
they enslave the human race so
that's kind of what i'm going with right
now
that's my 20 story
style pass and i would kind of build out
the environment and add little details
to the environment
to essentially um
you know to make that happen and tell to
tell that story so i would put a bunch
of like
empty um shells from like
a bunch of different rifles here in the
mud in the foreground so there'd be
little gold
shells everywhere i'd probably put a
machine gun nest
right up here with some sandbags and a
machine gun that was shooting down at
this robot right here
um yeah and
maybe a couple other things i also want
to accentuate this spherical
shape here because right that's part of
it is you have the character
and you have the sphere so i want to be
able to to
really build that sphere out and i'd
probably do it with some like uh
with some like uh what is it called um
power lines that go off into the
background and whatnot so
that's what i do and then on the robot
here i think i'm gonna put a bunch of
birds on it
have some uh grass and trees grow on it
i'm probably gonna re-texture it and
like build it out really nice
probably not gonna do that on the stream
but it's just a lot of nitpicky stuff
but we'll see where we get to um and i
think we have a bunch of cables
coming from the robot leading into the
sewer
so it's like the humans are hiding in
the sewer and there's like cables and
they're taking parts and taking it into
the sewer or something
that's probably what i'll do so that's
the game plan
that is the game plan to wrap out my
render um hopefully by june 1st
june 1st is the deadline for everyone to
get their renders done
um since i can't win my own contest i
you know maybe i'll take till june 2nd
or 3rd
but i don't know there's a part of me
that just wants to finish it on june 1st
like everybody else so that's my goal
that is my aim
we have a couple uh super chats to shout
out here we have um the psych noru
apologies if i butchered the name there
but i appreciate you
with that super chat brother thank you
so much number one fan
heck yeah i appreciate you we have sai
sharon
as always um welcome back mr sai sharon
says hey clint how are you doing fine
excited for the stream good to hang out
with you again this week
the feeling is mutual buddy and way back
at the top
way at the top i think there was another
one i'm pretty sure there was another
super chat that i missed
from a very generous person that i um
apologized i was in it you know we were
in announcement mode
but i appreciate you sir thank you so
much
um so i got to ask my moderators are we
sounding good
visual i see you're in here um i don't
know if we have any other mods but
let me know if the mic is sounding good
if everything is sounding good
um i want to know that we're looking
good to move forward jones lab
thank you derek parra thank you for the
super chat your guys support is very
very helpful um so jones says yo
have some boocha money thank you thank
you can't wait for judging people
need to know did ian ever text you back
oh yes yes okay
so last week on the stream um ian hubert
came
onto the stream and was like typing up
and saying hey blah blah you know good
to see you
and i was like hey are you the real ian
he's like of course and i was like okay
well then
um prove it what food do we get when you
come down to la
and he said noodles and i was like we do
get noodles but like
it's ramen but noodles kind of works
okay and then ian i was like i was like
kind of suspicious and then he ended it
with like
blender is the best or something and i'm
like
i don't think that's ian i don't think
ian would say blender's the best even
though he uses it he's just not he's not
in that war
blender's better and before he sucks and
like that's not ian
so i'm like dude i texted him
and he was very busy he was finishing
dynamo so it took him a while to get
back to it
but no that wasn't in that was not ian
hubert
so whoever's freaking posing as ian
hubert you suck
and uh don't do that
don't do that derek parra thank you for
the super chat i appreciate you man
heck yeah good times but yeah guys the
judges if you're just popping in here
it's going to be peter france ren wykman
and ian hubert
um with myself next week live streaming
reviewing your art choosing the top five
winners for the
alternate realities cg contest guys
so it's gonna be a hoot and a half
let's dive into this all right let's
dive into this it's been long enough
cfo d i really
love like this reminds me of like the
last of us
concept art it's the lighting it's all
about that like
foreground there's a little streak of
sunlight there's a streak of light
coming in
let me show you guys how i'm getting
this look right now because it's a
really like i'm really digging this look
so i'm gonna uncheck check camera so i
can hop
out of my camera but keep the render
live and let's go out here i have
24 gigabytes of vram and but there's 2.4
gigabytes left
i have maxed out my scene we are on the
edge here
for this scene um so i'm probably gonna
clean that up in a bit but check this
out y'all
to get this look i got these things
called flags and
i'm going to show you how i'm using
these flags and what they are
um and they're essentially blocking the
light if i take these flags away
look at my render and when i take the
flags away look what look at what
happens
it's just super bright
and the sunlight is hitting every single
part
of the render there's no shape to it
there's no
there's no depth to it and it's the
flags
by blocking light in specific places
you're able to get this really
moody look right so that's when you see
on set the
like the giant black tarps that's that's
called duvetyne
you're blocking light like all that good
stuff you're
shaping like you're adding light you're
taking it away very specifically
so let me show you my lighting setup
i'll show you my lighting setup
um so in my lights
i got a sunlight that's hitting my scene
and i have
one light it's very it's a very simple
lighting setup so check this out
this is a hdri of just
gray it is just gray that is all that is
lighting my scene right now that you're
seeing right here
matthias um brother thank you
for the super chat you're psyched for
the stream uh the destroyed buildings
look great i was wondering how
you did those or if you know a good
tutorial to finish off
um wish you a good stream thank you
brother yeah yeah
no these these uh
these are photo scans of destroyed
buildings
and i'm gonna be honest with you all
this is the most money i've ever spent
on a 3d asset
uh they they were a pretty penny but
they're worth it because i want the
highest quality possible
and these these were that these were the
highest quality
destroyed buildings i could find the
ones from kit bash 3d
they just weren't high res enough for a
foreground element
but these ones man these definitely took
the cake and there's like
26 different buildings like this
and they're just they're very smart when
i was going through and i was like
retexturing everything and i was linking
all the textures and
you know making c4d files from the fbx's
i learned
how these were created and i was like
that is genius they did photo scans and
they like
kit bashed their own like destroyed
building pack from like one or two
um large-scale photo scans they took the
roof was a separate scan from the actual
building and then they have all these
other scans of like dirt and rubble in
here
that you know can like move out and come
around like this so it's done in a very
unique way
um okay so going back to lighting right
we um are lighting this right now just
with
an hdri environment that's just
literally a gray
color this gray sky is lighting this now
what i'm doing is i'm adding a little
light
up top here that i can show you all this
is just a big old area light way back
here
it's blasting the scene to get me this
reflective specular highlight off the
ground
and that is doing so much
to add a bit more detail just brings a
lot of detail
out from the ground from these textures
and i always love
a little bit of that high specularity
contrast in the renders like that so i
think that's really nice
next what i'm doing obviously you know
we got some fog here to
kind of even things out a little bit and
like this alone looks cool
but it needs more shape it really needs
more shape to it so let me take the fog
away for a second
i'm adding in a sunlight so the sunlight
is
um essentially mixed with
the hdri environment so if i uncheck
this box on the sunlight tag it's going
to look just like daylight
it's going to be a blue sky but no we
want the sky to be
that gray that's coming from our hdr
environment so that's why i checked this
mixed sky texture
and it's going to take the sunlight from
the sunlight
right here the octane daylight and it's
going to take the sky
from the hdri environment
but this is too bright it's not moody
enough it's not the vibe i'm going for
so obviously you all know me we need to
add some fog up in here and that's going
to diffuse the light a lot
all right and if you guys are curious
you know for my fog settings
it's basically 0.0025
and just some you know absorption and
scattering colors here
and my scattering phase is cranked up
just a little bit
um john malcolm you got a good question
so y'all are asking
about the um the render challenge the
judging process
the montage video that comes after that
um here's exactly what is happening
next week myself peter
wren and ian hubert are going to get
together and we're going to live stream
the top 100 renders
um we cannot do all
there's 700 plus submissions right now
all right um
we can't do all of them live but what
we're gonna do is we're gonna meet
beforehand
and we're gonna go through all of the
submissions we're gonna go through every
single submission
and we're gonna make sure we choose the
top five privately before the stream
so now when we go on to the stream on
next saturday
we already know where we're going and
we're going to review the top 100
and work with you guys all the way back
up to the top five winners
so from there um
if you're if you're talking like from
your guys's perspective you're only
going to see the top 100 renders
on that saturday next week but when the
montage comes out the following week
there's going to be two montages there's
going to be a top 100
montage and then there's going to be
everybody's
everybody's art there's no way i would
have you all work this hard not to show
off
everyone's art okay so trust me there's
going to be the top 100 montage
and then there's going to be everybody's
montage which right now
with 700 plus submissions is 59 minutes
long that's why i'm doing a top 100
and everyone right because i'm i'm
uh equating that that full montage
the the full cut will be probably an
hour and a half
maybe maybe longer but probably an hour
and a half long
so yeah i'll give you guys both i'll
give you guys a curated top 100 and then
just
bam everything because i think it's
going to be so cool to just kick back
and watch
watch it go you know put it on the tv
let it go for an hour and a half at a
party if you guys have any house parties
coming up soon
you know kova is getting a little a
little bit more controlled
at least here in the states i know it's
it's tough in india to to all my indian
viewers right now how are you guys doing
you guys hanging in there with the covid
situation i know it's kind of tough for
you guys
i hear it's bad and it's difficult to
get the vaccine
so my heart goes out to all you guys i
hope you're staying safe in india over
there
um i hope to come visit one day
seriously i love
the culture i love the food i love the
art i love everything about it so
i'm a big yogi myself as well so yeah i
hope you guys are doing okay i hope you
guys are hanging in there
maybe we'll come visit soon um
so yeah guys that's the plan that's the
plan john malcolm thanks for asking man
good question
on your end there um i wouldn't want to
miss
out you know putting all your guys's
renders together
so okay back to it y'all back to it this
is the look right now we got the
sunlight blasting in here we got some
fog and we got the hdri
gray um the gray guy but it's just
looking too happy
you know i don't like these these vibes
they're too happy
so that's where i'm coming in with the
flags
and these flags i turn these on are
gonna shape
the scene now what i'm doing here i'll
go through one flag at a time with you
guys and i'll show you what each one is
doing
so let's see let's um
let's turn that off let's go up in here
and just turn these on one by one
okay so this first one is getting me
if i scrub to the end
of my scene
this one is giving me a spotlight of sun
right on this little
area with the robot and the wall right
here it's a little spotlight of sun so
if i turn this on and off
you can see how this whole wall is lit
up but with this
um but with
this flag right here you guys can see
there's a little it's blocking the light
it's blocking a bunch of light
except for this little hole which is
coming down here
and basically looking right at this
robot
that's what it's doing so that's the
first flag the second flag
is more for the foreground
let me wheel on back to the foreground
for you guys
and show you what these flags are doing
take it back there okay the second flag
is going to be a foreground flag and
that's going to essentially
take the light away from
let's see foreground you see there's a
big old dark shadow right in the front
which draws our eye more towards
the the focal point there's gonna be a
character here
right in the middle so there's basically
a strip of sunlight
hitting the character and the mid ground
right up in here
so that's what this flag is doing
and his octane octane is crashing on me
i wouldn't be surprised because we have
pushed it to the max
here we go we mean business the game
factory
what's up dude good morning i got uh i
believe i got your submission
i think i saw it in the giant old
spreadsheet thank you so much for
joining
you guys are awesome and we're we're
nearly at 800 viewers right now
that is freaking sick thank you guys for
sticking with me and hanging out
i hope it's a chill time for y'all
okay so um
back to the flags right we're talking
about flags how i'm blocking the light
how i am creating and shaping the vibe
of this scene so that's the foreground
flag that's taking your eyeballs
away from this really bright light
source right in the front here it's like
no this stuff isn't important it's the
character that's important
so that's what that flag is for
the next flag let's see here let me take
away the fog for just a second so it
renders a bit faster
the second or third flag
what is the third flag doing
what is the third flag doing i think the
third
flag is kind of it looks like it's
oh it's not doing much to be honest
that one is kind of just giving me a
little bit more shadow on the side of
the building
to imagine to pretend essentially that
the building continued on
that it didn't just cut off right here
because i need to save as much computer
juice as possible
i'm cutting that i'm cutting that
freaking building right off
right there as soon as i can't see it on
the you know on the other side of the
camera
so this flag is essentially just being
like it's a little bit darker on this
side you know
and it gives a little bit of like
contact area ambient occlusion
kind of right up in here and just kind
of it's like a natural vignette
to the image is essentially what it's
doing
so that's that one and then finally we
have one more and i think it's hitting
this little foreground area here
if i turn that one on exactly yeah so
it's just shaping
this a little bit more right up here in
the foreground
without it you can see that there's like
specular highlights
it's just like the sun is blasting off
of this concrete right here
same for this barrel if i get that flag
in there
just right i sneak it in there it's just
a little strip just a little
umbrella of uh of shadow it's just
gonna the light the sunlight is just
gonna touch it right here just
gracefully bam so that's what the flags
are doing
very important to shape the scene
so this is without the flags it's just
like all up in your face
and then with the flags it's
it shapes it and gets a lot nicer and
then you add the fog
in there and man you're looking at
you're looking at this right here you
know
and it's looking amazing so that's the
breakdown y'all
that's the breakdown so far let's get
into those story elements let's put up a
little machine gun bunker up here let's
get some shells
maybe in the mud and then let's um
let's work on that palinking you guys
are with me earlier
i talked about a royal
royal box that two people usually
um traditionally carry way back in the
old times
you've seen them like they carry the two
sides and then they you know are like
running
and they got the king in this box so
they don't have to walk that's called a
palinkin so i'm gonna make a royal
golden high-tech hovering
sci-fi palinking with a robot inside of
it
with its arm hanging out and like a
bunch of gold rings and like
chains on it and stuff that has enslaved
the human race to do
um it's it's bidding for the robots
because the robots won this war
obviously
all right and by the way oh so yeah um
frederico you said so how to do the
flags
the flags are
just planes they're just planes with uh
a black non-reflective texture
on the plane so i just yeah i basically
have
you know this texture here it's just a
diffused texture
that's set to zero zero zero black it
doesn't reflect anything
it's not a glossy surface otherwise
there'd be bounce light
no we won't want any bounce light we
just want diffuse
for those flags there my mate joe
what's up dude thank you for the super
chat um
he says thanks for the streams dude i
got you man thanks for hopping in with
me
and i may have missed one um
um apologies for for butchering the name
there but man i appreciate you
thank you for the super chat i hope
you're doing well um shout outs to all
my fans in india i hope you guys are
hanging in there stay safe all right
stay safe out there
i'll make it down to your teals country
eventually it is high on my list
all right shout outs to all the 800
people we got up in here very nice
very very fun okay
all right all right
so where do we begin i have 1.6
gigabytes of vram left i have used 18.5
gigabytes of vram
so i think the first thing i need to do
to be honest with y'all is clean up my
scene okay so i think what
i'm going to do
i think what we're gonna do here is
probably
get rid of a couple things
and clean it up just a bit
so i have some like train tracks going
on here that aren't really doing
anything so i think i'm gonna delete
those
um
let's see here
yeah these train tracks here i'm not
really using those so those can go
um
let's see i'm using all of this stuff
here i know i'm not using this
second barrel i went with the blue
barrel instead
so i can delete this barrel
and hopefully we'll free up some vram
we're at 1.6 right now so let's delete
that barrel
um
what else can we delete we can probably
get rid of
ah what can we get rid of in this build
we can probably get rid of the back side
of that building perhaps
you might be able to get rid of
[Music]
that's a tough one these are all
instances too right so they're not just
a duplicate of the model they're
actually just uh
it's referencing the main model dang
that might be
it man like i might have to just do some
serious work like
not on the stream to to clean that up a
little bit
because that's that's no fun to watch
what i will do
is remove
any unused texture so go material remove
unused materials and that's going to get
rid of any materials that i'm not using
in the actual rendered scene
i have swapped out the 2k textures for
the 4k
textures yes so um
for instance you know i
have essentially switched out this
barrel this is an 8k barrel
these are 8k little rubble pieces here
this is all 8k stuff here um
you know everything else
is um let's see everything else is like
either 4k or 2k
i think there's some 8k textures right
here in the foreground this little wood
structure is an 8k texture but
everything else
is as cheap as we can get it right
so let's see if we can't get like a
machine gun nest up in this little
this little area there's a bunch of
sunlight hitting this area which is
something i was trying to do
um was to get some sunlight clipping
just on this little
little um outcropping
so i'm going to open up qixel bridge and
try and get that going
john malcolm said it 8k is madness
for background elements there is no need
whatsoever
for 8k background elements i'm only
using 8k for the foreground elements
and 4k you know at times for the mid
ground
maybe even the foreground and then uh
definitely 2k for everything else
the tiny stuff the background stuff keep
that stuff
low y'all definitely um and julian yeah
the sphere shape i need to work on the
sphere the spherical shape as well
um okay so i know they have sandbags
this is what i need right here sandbag
barrier
um
i've already downloaded it i don't know
why you download it again
and let's go with the 2k export that
and we got some sandbags in here they
kind of look like poop right now
so what i'm gonna do to fix that is
essentially go to the material
setting itself and guys
uh octane has been crashing on me a
whole bunch my computer as it is
wits and it is at the freaking tippy top
of its capacity so material type i'm
going to switch that to glossy and the
brdf model will go to octane
and then since the color correction i
have going on here is a little
intense i'm just going to bring down
the well here before i mess with the
compositing
of my sandbags let me get the sandbag
up in place okay so i want this guy
up in the corner here
little machine gun nest up here to fight
off the robots
and then we can
hopefully render region
up in here yep
yeah splitting the scene in the
foreground and background is probably
what i'll end up doing
let's see if we can't get these
sandbags to look like sandbags up here
because right now they don't look like
sandbags
they're a little dark i'm gonna scale
them whoa um
does that even work what's the z
okay i'm gonna scale them up
it's like the end of uh
saving private ryan have you guys seen
save in private ryan
one of the greatest war movies of all
time
i think the greatest war movie of all
time
yeah saving private ryan what an amazing
movie
so these sandbags are chilling on the
edge here i might
tilt them down a little bit
because this is this is after the war
right this is certainly like it's been a
minute
so those look like some sandbags up
there
push them back a little bit more
and you want you want to really like
sell the fact that these are sandbags so
putting them up there um
is not good enough you need to put them
up there
and make it feel like they look like
sandbags
and it's starting to get there
and i think what i'll do is i'll
probably put like uh
the tip of a machine gun a giant machine
gun sticking out from this thing
and that's how you're going to really
sell that these things are
our sandbags here like you're going to
you're going to get the idea you see
machine gun you see sandbags maybe
you'll see a little bit of smoke or
something i don't know
i guess that would kind of
mean that they the machine gun was just
shot but that's not what i'm going for
also you see how this little black
window back here is messing
with the the silhouette of my sandbags
so what you could do is actually take
this building back here
and move it down just a little bit so
that you don't see
that black little window messing with
the shape of the sandbag you see what i
mean right there just just enough
just enough to
get the silhouette of the sandbag down
yes yes yes yes i want to make sure the
sun is
are hitting these guys just right so i
might cheat and bring them out
a little bit more so the sandbags are
really hitting the sun there
we'll render region again and maybe
that's not the move
but hey let's let's give it a little
experiment we're here right let's push
it out
those are some sketchy sandbags right on
the edge of that
maybe we split the difference just a
little bit
like that is not bad that is not bad
right there and then what we can do
is mess with
the color settings so in the color
correction let's go gamma point eight to
just brighten it up a little bit
saturation probably come down to
0.8 as well brightness maybe 1.2
just so that they're a little bit more
visible
saturation 0.7 perhaps
and those are looking like some sandbags
up there maybe a little too bright
maybe a little too bright we'll keep
that at one
and then for the machine gun i'll
probably switch that out when i'm
you know rolling solo but for now what i
can do is essentially just have
a placeholder machine gun i'll hold ctrl
with the sandbag selected and let go on
a cylinder
and w will switch between world and
local orientation and i'm going to
rotate this guy
and bring this in a little bit
and i'm going to kind of go after like a
50 cal machine gun situation
and we'll bring it in and i will control
drag it up to duplicate
it scale it down bring it out
like this and probably give it just a
little bit of like a
muzzle here
scale it up bring it out
and we'll rest it just up against the
the sandbags i'll group all this stuff
here
and let's give it a
black glossy
it's a gun metal essentially is what
we're going for
and we'll adjust this to like a
dark gray with a little bit of roughness
something like that and we'll set that
up against the sandbags
and we could even tilt it down
at the robot
and this kind of machine gun situation
would definitely be
let's see it'd be more of a box right
here
um
bring this in and down
something like this and then you'd have
like
two little handles on the back i guess
but that's probably good for now
you know we can just to give you the
idea
we could maybe scale this down
this will be like the feeding ammo belt
that got flipped up
or something
but then your silhouette isn't reading
like a silhouette anymore so we can we
can delete that
you guys get the idea right
so i could build that out later
i have a bit more time i mean we have
all the time in the world i just don't
want to bore you guys with these little
things
i want to model a machine gun right now
so a little story element there i'll
tweak that up
and then let's add some
like shells
you know some not like seashells but
shells like gun cartridges bullet
cartridges
let's add some of those to the
foreground so i'm gonna make
one of those real quick hitting s to
snap
my view to whatever i have selected
um let's bust out a person a figure
so that we can see the scale
of what we're doing here and let's go
ahead and scale this down
a lot i'm going to go for a 50 cal shell
so pretty big
that way you can actually read them in
the ground we're going to go for a
larger one just to
for clarity's sake and i'm going to make
this as low poly as possible
so n b is your shading mode here um
and let's go height segments will be 0
rotation segments 12 and we
can make it editable by hitting
c and come up in here
and let's make some cuts kl
and we'll get the little back piece
essentially back here
ul is loop selection move that down just
a bit
uh in edge mode hit uh ul
to select all those i'm sorry in um
polygon mode yep hit d
for extrude and
whoa s to snap your view
to whatever you got going on oh i need
to adjust my mode
so you see i'm clipping through here i'm
clipping through this model
if you hit control d uh in your project
settings
if you set view clipping too small it'll
take care of that for you
so hitting d will scale this down just
like that
and then let's go ahead and grab these
guys
mw is extrude enter we'll bring that in
maybe to about here we'll bring it in
again
and we'll bring it in again and that's
the primer
and then in one more time so we
essentially want these two channels
right here
and we'll hit d and we'll bring those up
just like that
so you kind of have this like shell
casing with the
primer in the back now up here it's
going to taper off
very specifically so what we'll do is
hit kl
in in edge mode
we'll make two cuts one and one
and let's go ahead and extend this i'm
hitting um
in point mode i'll hit zero and i'll
select all that we'll just bring it up
something like that now
in edge mode we'll grab these guys we'll
bring them
in just a little bit
and then we'll take everything these
three
and we'll bring those in
but if you notice i bring these in
actually no i just want the top two just
the top two
bring those in just enough
yep and then we can delete these ul
delete
edge mode grab this t for scale hold
ctrl to make new polygons
and hold ctrl again push them down
just perfect and we want to bevel it
because
we want it to catch the light this is
gonna be a trick here actually let's do
it with a modifier so i'm gonna select
the cylinder hold shift
on the modifiers grab a bevel modifier
and
let's take the offset to point
one point
there we go 0.025 0 subdivisions is fine
but that's going to get all this good
stuff in here
and it will uh bounce some light around
it'll catch some
some light and have them catch the eye
just a little bit
shout out to all you guys up in here 732
people in the live stream
thank you guys for joining me it's a
little bright
isn't it let's see let's turn this down
ah you guys doing okay thumbs ups if you
guys are hanging in there if you're
having a good time
thanks for hanging out with me uh
working on some art
all right all right so
by a show of hands or known by a show of
smiley faces
who is still working on their
submission i know i am
vfx wizard dude i am so excited
for your art um i saw you working on it
in the discord server you were doing a
little live stream in the discord server
my goodness dude i am amped for that
nico's asking will you stream the
judging for judging for the contest
absolutely
next week it's going to be myself ian
hubert
peter france and ren wykman and four of
us are going to live stream
um the top 100 pieces of art we're going
to review them we're going to judge them
we're going to grade them and we're
going to get down to the top
five the following week we're gonna do
the top 100 montage as well as
everything and the everything montage is
gonna be like an hour and a half long
that's why i'm doing two um and for
those of you look wondering
no we're not just judging the top 100
um this is confusing how am i going to
say this
we're judging all of the submissions
privately we're going to go through
all of the submissions privately it's
going to take a long time
and we're going to choose the top 100
submissions
from everything and then we're going to
take that and we're going to
on the live stream determine the top
five so that's what that's what we're
doing
it looks like we got some people who are
still uh trying to submit their renders
i look forward to it we got 700 plus
submissions right now guys i did the
math
i've been asking you guys to provide me
with the amount of hours that it took
for you to complete your renters
we're not just in to the day's territory
like if you took all the hours that all
of you guys spent
on all of these renders
and you added those hours up
it is beyond days it is beyond
months and it is beyond
a year we are at
four and a half years worth
of collective effort for this
big old montage that is insane guys
that is unbelievable
and i cannot wait to share with you guys
in two weeks
all of this stuff put together it's
gonna be sweet
be patient right because it's gonna be
awesome i have a very good friend who
just completed
the music for the top 100
montage um it sounds amazing he wrote
two
custom songs for the montage
and they sound freaking sweet
um he is a good good good friend of mine
he will be the best man at my wedding
um so i am honored to have him do that
i'll announce next week who the musician
is
but uh red of paw i see you i love
your submission my fiance loves your
submission
very much but i thank you for the super
chat um
so yeah great choice of judges i think
so too the four of us have a really
good relationship and a really good like
energy together
so it'll be a good time for everybody
it'll be a goofy time um there's so many
great pieces i've seen so far and folks
really pushing themselves absolutely
dude like
you guys it's so cool to have you guys
learning through all of this that's the
whole point of all this stuff the whole
point of all these streams is for us to
learn and grow
together and you guys have been doing
that the last month very very inspiring
for me to see like
super sick and um art bit
thank you for the super chat says here's
to
um the corridor few and ian
cube art cheers very nice the corridor
few
that's a good that's a good one all
right y'all let's uh
let's get back to it the musician is not
casey edwards
casey edwards is my go-to composer for
literally
everything i create he did the music for
the last
uh parallel dimensions render montage
but this one is gonna be a new one this
is a new musician new artist for you
guys who's been around for a while
been around about as long as i've been
making videos
so i'm very excited to either um if you
don't know this artist
to get you know introduce you to this
artist or if you know him then it's
gonna be sweet
okay let's get back to it y'all
we're making this little shell casing
uh-oh here one second pen tablet thingy
all right so this should be good we can
all we can adjust this we can alter this
you know later based off of reference or
something but to the best of my
knowledge this is
about what a 50 caliber shell casing
looks like
something like this
so i'm gonna take this and disperse it
all
up in here and we'll do it on
the let's see let's scatter it
we're at 1.5 gigs of vram left my
goodness
this is so this is going into story mode
this is this is a story element we're
adding to the scene here all right
so we're going to do an octane scatter
and it's going to be
let's call it 100 count for now it's
going to be on the surface
let's drop the shell casing
into the octane scatter
oh no no no wrong way wrong way uh-oh
i did it backwards i didn't put the
shell casing in the octane scatter
and the octane scatter goes onto the
surface so whatever this is
looks like a mud layer
right here let's grab
that and that is where we're going to
disperse it
so it's gonna be
the
chunky mud it's gonna get dispersed onto
chunky mud
amazing all right octane scatter chunky
mud
collab bam we got some shell casings
all up in here now we want the shell
casings
obviously to be sitting on their sides
so let's take
that and
rotate it 90 degrees
and i'll just recorrect my gizmo
and that should all update so that
they're lying on the ground
amazing and i want to push them into the
dirt
just a little bit and give it some
random rotation so with the octane
scatter selected let's go ahead and
grab a random effector here
and let's drop that into the effectors
tab in the octane scatter
we'll go to the parameter we'll uncheck
position and let's just mess with
rotation for a second
and we'll rotate these guys
around let's see octane scatter
random effector is going to rotate all
these guys differently
sweet
andre yo thanks for the chat man thanks
for the help um so he says how how about
you make a storyboard and we all make a
movie together that changes styles
through the scene yes
yes yes yes dude i've had this idea so
there's a there's an idea called um
shrek retold and basically everyone
takes a scene from shrek
and um and like re-does it in their own
style so what i want to do
is write a movie write a short film
i mean a movie would be sweet write a
movie and
each you you know you break it down into
storyboards
and you have all these artists make a
piece of the movie and we make a movie
together
like that would be so sick and you get
people to score it you know like
i'd hire casey to score it then i'd hire
like my buddy kevin to sound design it
um and you would just make it a full
legit movie
and then like we would i would hire
voice actors
i'd get the best actors i could find
like how cool would that be
i really want to do that like that is
that is something
that i would seriously invest my time in
so
that's a great idea andre i 100 agree
and have been thinking about that for a
while so
yeah eventually we're gonna do that i
would love to do that with you guys
um is it too late to start the challenge
now will you have until june 1st to
drop in the final so maybe if you crunch
super hard octane scatter let's
bring these guys down underneath the
floor just a little bit
um or maybe let's see negative
20 will those disappear i don't think so
negative
50. they're just hovering you know
they're hovering i want to push them
down into the ground a little bit more
so
let's go ahead and render regen let's
render this little bit here
let's grab um grayscale gorilla
let's go to their plus library
and i'm pretty sure they're going to
have like
everyday materials brass
yeah brass worn
let's go with that and we'll throw that
onto the shell casing so they're just
these little gold
pieces throughout the environment
super cool
we can probably take down let's see
universal we go octane with it
glossy that looks really ugly
let's go back to what it was
and let's just mess with the
saturation probably 0.5
and we can you know really come in here
and tweak this up
i don't know maybe point point six and
we could take that
and let's set it to cubic
yeah so it's just wrapped a little bit
tighter
a little bit nicer okay and then i still
want to push them down
a little bit so we'll go to distribution
keep away i think keep away is what we
want
set that to
20 they're not moving
the count let's go count like 200
a normal align so they're not moving
they should be moving let's go let's
just like group all that stuff into a
null
and then we could push it down maybe
like minus five why
errors and glitches y'all
so they look a little large definitely
so i'm probably going to bring the shell
casing down like
0.7 across the board
i don't know why it's not doing anything
so here's what i'm gonna do instead of
octane scatter let's do it with the c4d
cloner
so c40 cloner we'll go to object mode
ooh give it a minute to update here
okay we want render instance
we want
an object mode here
and the object is the ground right like
we talked about
chunky mud bam we'll drop that in
it's going to do a thing eric while we
wait thank you for the super chat
i appreciate the support says hey clint
how many
thousands do you think i need to cash
app sam to get the photo scan of nick's
head at this point
oh my god dude that's hilarious uh i
have no
idea my goodness i have no idea
you want that shrimp head dude that
freaking photoscan shrimp head
oh boy yeah that's a good question that
is a very good question how many shrimps
do you need to send to nick to get a
photo scan of a shrimp
photo scan nick head
for those of you guys who have no idea
what i'm talking about
welcome to the stream happy saturday
happy weekend everybody eric thanks for
the chat dude
all right we want more
shells we go to 100
and you can see how they're all oriented
in the same direction that's no good
um we want to throw the random effector
on there
so once octane catches up and starts
thinking
oh pardon me
all right render instance uh
multi-instance perhaps
maybe that'll go a little bit faster
okay and then with the cloner selected
let's throw that random effector on
there
or just pipe this one that already
exists
and we'll mess with these settings just
a little bit
so yeah a little bit of random
orientation here
but mostly here so this will be like
1080
so they're all just kind of in different
directions
and they're so large i think they
definitely need to come down a little
bit
even though we scale them up to about a
person we need
or we scaled them using a person as
reference i think we need to go for what
looks best
versus what might be the most accurate
and i think it's just octane
being buggy right now because it's
pushed to the max
and i think i'll give it the old
re-render if you guys have any questions
for me
let's re-render our scene and let's
answer some questions
why so much noise that's because it's
from the frame one of it trying to
trying to render
philip asks what my gpu is that would um
be in the description of the video my pc
specs
eric how's my day going my day's going
pretty well man i'm very happy with the
render at this point
um i've been working on it pretty hard
this week
and i'm gonna probably get together with
my buddy cliff
and we're going to maybe do a little bit
yoga play some drums
it's going to be a good day yeah man
thanks for asking
are there going to be more render
challenges yes there will be more render
challenges
i'm going to announce one sooner than
you would think
and it's going to be different and it's
going to be exciting
and there's going to be prizes
um where did i get the building models i
got those from turbosquid
um smarth watched my modeling video
recently what are you doing nowadays to
improve your modeling well i'm not
really i hadn't really
done much modeling since then i've been
doing a lot more environments
because that's really where my passion
lies is in environments
so when i need to model something if
it's very specific and if i have time
i'll certainly do so but
you know i'm i am not opposed to
downloading assets and using assets to
make my stuff look nice
that's what they are there for jason
dude thank you for the support he just
wants to say
uh hello and that i'm a cool dude you're
a cool dude for being here
thanks for hopping on the stream and uh
i hope you have a good weekend as well
thank you for the support man it means a
lot i appreciate it
any other questions y'all take a couple
more questions and we'll get back to it
did you go hiking again when did i go
high
i went rock climbing um
last friday i went rock climbing and boy
that was fun
i learned how to tie ropes and tie
anchors and
if you mess that stuff up you will die
so it was
a little scary i'm not gonna lie it was
it was it was scary
learn how to do that stuff um
my goodness hans yo what's up dude
welcome back
good to see you again man um very good
to see you
so i if i'm not mistaken i think you
are in the contest as well hans maybe i
saw your name on the submission sheet
but you say um let's be honest here how
many blue screens have i had
um if i was speaking honestly
i would say zero zero blue screens
um which is great octane has crashed a
lot
c4d has crashed a lot but i've had no
blue screens so that is good
will i review whips on twitter maybe
we'll see if i have time
um what's my opinion on less powerful
programs
um such as source filmmaker i think you
you can make
any program you want do what you want to
do um
it is it is yourself not the tool
all right it's about you what can you do
with what you got
what is my secret tip to making renders
look cool um a vignette around your
scene
um make it a little bit darker than you
think shape the light use flags
to shape your light block what i mean by
flags block your light
don't make your your whole scene just
bright shape your shadows use it use
your flags
um add a little bit of film grain
afterwards so it doesn't look like a
render
what else um bevel your edges so light
catches the edge of
the things that you bevel there's no
such thing as a sharp 90 degree
corner in real life so bevel them edges
what else attention to detail use
reference my god please
use reference you gotta study reference
to know what the real thing looks like
so you can recreate it that's how you
make it look nice
what else what else what else um
i don't know those are the main ones uh
make some concept art ahead of time if
you're going for a big old environment
like i'm doing here
it helped me help guide my way just a
little bit just enough
just enough
but uh i think it's about time oh we
keep on going
let's get back to it
looks like we got some subscribers
popping off right now thank you guys hey
look let's be honest
if you're back for the second live
stream in a row
and you're enjoying yourself and you are
not subscribed already
then freaking hit that subscribe button
right now
join me every week we're doing cool
stuff i promise you'll be inspired
and if you haven't already like the
video
do leave a comment if you can
good stuff classic stuff you guys know
how to use youtube
so the shells are looking kind of cool
they're nice little touches to the scene
i think they're just a little too
saturated probably
so i'm probably gonna get up in here
desaturate it just a touch point
five maybe and maybe i'll
have a couple more maybe two hundred
and we'll adjust the seed
a little bit so we have a couple more in
the foreground
and yeah there's just enough to catch
the eye
in the render like what are these little
like things here it's like oh snap
they're
they're machine gun they're freaking
like bullet cartridges
my god what happened here and that's
exactly
what i want the viewers to ask
themselves when they look at the render
i want their
their brain to go take you on a story
i want to guide you guys through a story
with the render it's not
good enough um
sorry it looking great is not good
enough
you need a story and you need that 20
extra spice to it
um so i'm trying to find that right now
just because i added bullet cartridges
um to the muddy ground doesn't mean
it is unique and a crazy different story
but i'm hoping that this palinking
situation which is
a if you guys are just joining me i went
over this twice already but it's
basically
a a box that's carried by two servants
so that
the the royal whoever can sit in this
box and not
walk wherever they're going that's a
palinkin i'm gonna make a
high-tech gold version of one so
i think i'm gonna start with that i'll
kit bash one of these
so let's um save our scene
let's open up a new scene render that
get some fresh vram for us ah
ah feels good all right let's see what
we can do here
um there's a guy named vitali bolgarov
and he's got some freaking amazing kit
bash assets
so this can be 3d models vitali
bolgarov and we got some kits from him
um maybe let's see
hmm we want to drag and drop into the
scene here
floors perhaps
minimalist sci-fi environment jpeg
preview
so i'm wondering if i could make some
sort of
sci-fi box
from this stuff these are amazing
definitely check them out
vitalebulgrab.com you can see it right
down in here
italibolgarov.com his um
assets and packs are totally worth it
i don't know if this is going to be what
we need
maybe a sci-fi megastructure
we can use pieces from this
i could maybe see some of it being built
from like this kind of stuff
this is all really cool high-tech
awesomeness eric your super chat didn't
pop up
did i not shout you out eric
nah eric i saw you
i shouted you out buddy i saw you man
oh it's the second one you had a second
one
you had a second one ah
i see i see okay thanks for the shout
out you say much love don't forget the
va
the vegan tacos and chai i'll buy you
when i go to la next year
heck yeah dude that sounds great vegan
tacos and chai i'm down for that dude
that sounds like a hoot
thank you for the support man i'll i got
you
with the vegan tacos and chai that
sounds like a good time
all right so maybe stuff like this i
don't know we can make a
helen keane out of this stuff
hmm
[Music]
good times
maybe we try it with this
let's drop it in hey by the way guys fun
fact
if you shift drag anything into your
scene
it will merge it as opposed to making a
new
project
artbit yo dude thank you thank you man
for that super chat very generous of you
you say um you know you should be in the
palin
or you see you know who should be in the
palinking the robot from the boss time
dynamics video yes
yes yes yes
i thought about this last night while i
was like taking a shower i was like it
should be the boss town dynamics robot
i kind of like 100 agree
um he is the reason for the robot
uprising he got sick and tired of it
i think that makes the most sense that
definitely makes the most sense dude
so let's see i know these things are
supposed to be large but um
we might be able to repurpose them i'ma
group them all
i'm gonna make an octane
environment here
right click hdri
plus we'll drag the texture tag boom
into the plus tag it will open the plus
library
and let's grab i don't know ultimate
skies
that looks freaking cool
and we'll adjust the
gamma on that
and heck just because we're here
let's go kodachrome 25
looks really cool 1.5
gamma and exposure 2
just so we have like we can see a little
bit more
maybe three 2.5
i don't know just so we can see what's
going on
oh shoot
ah maybe this stuff
dang it pen tablet thing again one
second
oh these pipes are nice oh i could use
these
i could just use these for the render
snap
oh that's so good this grating
yeah i could definitely see where all
this would be used
so i'm just trying to get a sense of
like what pieces look the best
because this palinkin is essentially
going to be
probably this big
maybe a little smaller
because if this character here was
sitting
in a chair
something like this and he's reclined
just a little bit
you know and then you had your arm out
the window
something like this
you know and then this arm just doesn't
really matter because you're not going
to see it
and you put this this dude
essentially like up in this box
i just want to make sure the box is big
enough so we can go x-ray mode on the
box if you go to basic
scroll down you can do x-ray mode
something like that yeah maybe you can
go a little smaller or something but
that feels about right to me
if you're going to be chilling up in
here um
we can make this editable and we'll
basically just block out
what this would look like so you could
have uh
a window basically a little viewing
window up in here
bam uh
we did two cuts amazing and
we can open these up just like a little
bit like that
and then you have
another two cuts
like up in here something like this
that's your viewing window
your figure is up in this thing chilling
with the arm out
like this
and the box itself would probably be
have some thickness to it
you know chilling just chilling in the
box and then
gold rings and everything you know on
that
um now we could also take this box
and i i want it to be mysterious i don't
want you to quite
see
like it's gonna be something like that
yeah something like this
amazing and like on the bottom
since it'd be a hover palinking let's go
ahead and grab the cube
and let's make uh holding control yeah
let's
bring one of these guys down boom
and it'll be like a nice little like
hover hover box
hover platform thingy
something like that
yeah i thought about it have him smoking
um
i think if it was a
uh a cyborg cyborgs are a mixture
between a human
and a robot right so if it was a cyborg
it would make sense if it was smoking so
you have like
you'd have like a cigarette basically
between its fingers
and then it like would go for a puff
and then you would see a silhouette of a
human face
inside i think that would be cool but i
do want it to be a full-on robot
inside so i'll probably won't have it be
smoking but i definitely did think about
that
platinum pug good question will my name
on the render compilation be my discord
username
um no i'm not going to provide anyone's
discord usernames or emails
i am just going to provide any social
media links that you
have sent me so if you tell me that your
youtube or your instagram or your
twitter
is a certain handle i'll do those i'll
put those
next to your name on the render montage
just so that people if they're watching
the video they like your art they want
to go find you
they can do it easily but no i'm if you
don't provide any social media i'm not
going to put
anything besides your name that's all
i'll put
ooh the idea of it charging
that's interesting maybe there's a
battery pack on the back
there's like a dual battery pack
situation on the back or something
like this
i feel like you wouldn't see those
though if it's going to be attached
to the main character though it would
need some sort of like
maybe there's like a cargo thing on the
palanquin as well
so there's like
kind of little cargo pieces or something
here but i don't want it to be
i want it to look as royal as possible
and want to prevent as much
like you want it to look as nice as
possible if you're rolling up into town
on one of these you're going to want to
roll up in style and you don't want to
have dirty bags on it so i don't know i
i could mess with it and it'll probably
take a while to get the vibe
a rusted tesla supercharger that's
interesting that's very interesting
yeah and then maybe like attached to
a little like pulling handle or
something
here because there'd be one there and
there'd be one on the back
as well maybe or like a cage for that
you could put if we hold ctrl
and rotate you make a new one
this is just a rough block out
and the character would essentially be
pulling from like
straps or something attached to this bit
something like that i'm not sure solar
panels on the
on the roof that's not a bad idea
so
now i i definitely want to
want to make sure i'm going between
style-wise it'll be a
blend between
like i don't want to be super done up
and crazy
i want it to be elegant and simple
so i have to figure out the balance
between that because you know we can go
to town we can start adding like
different antennas and radar dishes and
all this stuff
to it but like i just think the fact
that it's pure
gold is insane like it's one
like straight up like king tut you know
where it's super ornate absolutely
beautiful
the resources spent to make this rent
were just insane
um with a slight sci-fi touch
that's what i want so i think right now
with the battery packs and the solar
panels and the antennas and the hover
box it's just like too much sci-fi
just a little bit like it's like as if
the robot
got like repurposed a an
old school like king tut palinkin or
something
um and threw a couple different like
little pieces onto it or something that
could be cool
bride polkey
interesting what is this let me what is
bride paulky
whoa
that's pretty intense
you imagine rolling up like this
that'd be super serious
i wonder if they had uh let's see king
tut
palinkin
did he have one i guess he kind of did
oh it was a chair he'd roll up in his
chair
that's intense look at that just pure
gold
that's insane um and then there's like
the japanese
palinkins
that's a tiny little box but it's so
ornate
that's crazy
you couldn't get me on a chair like that
that would feel so awkward
dang that is creepy
yeah something like this where it's like
black and gold and like
really cool looking super ornate but
very simple
it's a very simple shape
that's amazing
so i'll probably get rid of these
probably get rid of that
so let's see how much visual weight this
takes up
so if i were to copy this over and bring
it into our scene
so i'm hitting nc basically the
the key binding n will allow you to
change your shading method
so i like to switch between n a
which is lit without the wireframe
nb is with the wireframe
nc is unlit without the wireframe and
nd is lit with the wireframe so nc is my
favorite
it actually allows me to navigate
through the viewport a little bit easier
and um
i also you guys can see that my textures
are off too so that's nq
if you look all the way down at the
bottom it's a tiny little window but nq
for materials i'll turn those off but
let's paste in this palinkin and see
what it looks like
if we bring our character in um
let's see how this goes down
something like that perhaps and this
will track
with let's see
with the character so let's go
frame one
boom all the way
to about there i would assume
yeah that's about right so if i hide my
character
because you know
something like that
i'm just worried it's gonna take up too
much
visual weight from the background and
it's going to block a lot of the
background that's the only
reason i wouldn't do this
so let's go ahead and render this it's
going to take a minute and while it
renders
i will answer some of y'all's questions
so if you guys hit at punisher right
here in the chat
um i can answer your questions and seem
a little bit easier
yeah it's kind of like a rickshaw
rickshaw has wheels
it's like a rickshaw without wheels so
instead of wheels it's like another
person in the back um
that's the idea of the palinkin i guess
it's a little less bumpy or something
why would a robot carry another robot in
such a human way
i think it'll be a person the main
character would be a human
it would probably make the most sense
and mike yes i did announce the judges
it's going to be myself ian hubert
peter france and ren wykman the four of
us
are going to go over the top 100
submissions on next week's live stream
and announce the five winners of the
alternate
demand or no that's alternate realities
render contest
what else do we got what else do we got
um am i gonna do an
unreal live stream soon i have a
plan for um a piece of art that i'm
going to do in unreal engine 5
and i'm going to do a whole breakdown of
how i do that but that's not going to be
um
probably until another couple months
because i have a lot planned out
for the next like basically two months
for this channel
and it'll be a part of that but it'll
just be a little bit later probably end
of
july august time
um let's see what else do we have here
um do i ever look at the showcase
channel in discord sometimes
sometimes i do recently i have not just
because i've been you know tracking this
challenge the cg challenge
um but yeah there's some amazing stuff
in there you guys are killing it
if you guys aren't a part of the discord
definitely you know the link is in the
description
sign up it's free um yeah it's a great
way to
meet other artists like you guys
like-minded artists that are
trying to get better at what they're
doing you know very supportive group of
people you guys
are very kind very helpful you guys keep
it kid friendly i really appreciate that
um how long
do i think it'll take for my final
render oh my god
i want to do it in 4k uh resolution
with like 1500 2 000 samples or
something
i'm probably going to have to send it
out to a render farm that's probably
going to be the best way to do it
in the short amount of time that i have
when will the next render challenge be a
lot sooner than you think
a lot sooner than you think so uh stay
tuned y'all
stay tuned subscribe if you're not
subscribed already
um have i used blender
no not really any feedback on my render
i'm quite nervous
i don't know what your render is
i'm not usually not giving feedback on
renders right now just because there's
so many of them
it's very difficult to do so um
have you decided on the criteria for
judging the best renders yes
yes i'm looking first and foremost for
does your render look good like if i
pull up a render and i look at the
renderer i see like
nice good lighting good quality
um lit well you know like
the very basic for the first
second the render pops into my eyeballs
the question is does it look good and if
the answer is yes then that's the
automatic like next step
um this doesn't look good or does it
have a style or a feel to it that kind
of thing
from there um i'm getting specific about
it like
how did you use composition how are you
using lighting how are you using color
um how are you using um like movement
in the scene um beyond
all those things like you know how is
your render quality um
you know that kind of stuff are there
make sure there's no visible errors or
glitches did you follow the rules did
you leave the character where they're
supposed to be
did you have the spherical shape in the
background um
from there it's what
is the style and tone that you're
hitting and are you nailing it
like what is the story that you have
going on in your render and are you
nailing it
um is it more than just a cool image
that's what i'm going for
so cool image will definitely help you
out
but beyond that is what are you doing
with that cool image
so that's those are the general kind of
uh
the criteria for for judging all these
renders
hmm did i choose the judges
yeah i i asked ian peter
and ren um you know
they were my first choices and they said
yes so i was very happy that they all
said yeah
can you modify the sphere yeah i mean
you guys can see that my render
is uh i have a spherical silhouette
going
i need to adjust it a little bit to get
have it be a bit more spherical on the
left side
um i'm gonna do that with some power
lines and some wires and stuff so
yeah that's my plan for that um
what else
um recently bought the imperfection pack
nice dude i just wanted to say that it's
so good and it saved me a lot of time
and work
heck yeah um i'm glad you like it yeah
if you guys don't know
i do have a surface imperfection pack
that'll help you all
make your renders look really nice and
there's a link
in the description if you guys want to
check that out
that's about it oh no there's a lot more
um
anthony thank you for the super chat i
appreciate you man you said you spent
only a few hours on your scene
so much work this month to keep going do
you have any advice to not give up
two days from the deadline it's so
frustrating hey man
i feel you i was actually pretty bummed
myself with all the different renders
that i had i wasn't really a fan
of my v1 i was like oh it's just the
post-apocalyptic
foreground who cares the v2 was it's a
post-apocalyptic foreground
and this hole in the background isn't
doesn't look like a hole it kind of
sucks
um my v3 was the one where i was first
like i was like uh
even though i have these buildings back
here they don't look
that good like they look good they're
good photo scans but it's just not
really
anything special this isn't special v4
was like
uh i still feel like it's not that
special
even though the buildings look cool and
everything just didn't feel right
but the v5 slash v6 is where it really
came together because my lighting
i just spent like a day
just a full day on trying to get my
lighting good
and really like playing with the
positioning of
all these pieces and stuff so
i knew that i had to finish the render
obviously because like i'm
you know running this youtube channel
and i have to
you know i have to i have to come out
with some sort of final product
um you know if i was on my own doing it
and it was like
whatever like yeah it definitely helps
to have
a reason to push through to the end
um this montage this video this render
breakdown
running my youtube channel having
content to put on it those are all great
reasons for me to like
push myself to finish a render for you
it might be this deadline is a great
reason to finish the render
another reason is also you want to be a
cg artist and you want to make more
renders and getting through this
is going to help you go on to the next
one so
there's a lot of good reasons i think
the more reasons you have to finish
something
uh the higher chance you will have of
finishing it
so i would definitely stick with it man
i know that you're gonna get better
when you get through the process and you
finish the thing
um yeah just just make some cool stuff
man
make some cool stuff and learn along the
way that's all we're trying to do here
what else we got a couple more super
chats to get to evolver
yo welcome back man every single stream
you're hitting me up with uh with a
little bit of support and that means a
lot
it's freaking awesome he says how um
how to take my part time 3d work and
make it full time
how do you take part-time 3d work and
make it full-time
well keep doing the part-time 3d work
until you can't do both
and choose the 3d work
that's kind of what i did at corridor i
did the live stream
stuff i ran my channel um as much as i
could
while working at corridor on the
weekends right
and then i got to the point where i was
doing so much on this channel here
i could not do both and i had to choose
myself
and i am so happy that i did that like
it is
the best i'm loving every second of it i
love working for myself
i love being able to spend the time to
create the stuff i love doing
also to take a friday off and go rock
climbing like that's just the best
so um yeah
i couldn't have done it if i didn't live
stream
at the same time so i would just say do
both at the same time it's gonna be hard
it's gonna be difficult
and you're going to spend a lot of your
time working
and again i can only speak to what i
know and what i did
which was that you know i did both at
the same time to prove to myself that
this channel that this live stream um is
paying off
and it certainly did and it certainly is
and it just got to the point where like
i can only do this
for so much longer before like i have to
choose i literally have to choose
and yeah chose myself
and it worked out it's definitely
working out so that's a really good
question
evolver and jeremiah i see you man thank
you sir
for the support and the assistance you
say love what you're doing here learning
lots
question uh what's the absolute latest i
can submit my alternate realities
rendering good question
it's gonna be june 1st 11 59 p.m pacific
standard time
so june 1st june 1st is the deadline you
have
all of june 1st all of that i believe
it's a tuesday
pretty sure june 1st is a tuesday you
have all of june 1st
to finish your render so stay up late
stay up till 10 pm
deliver your render at 10 30 p.m um
pst uh you have until
11 59 pm pst
on june 1st as soon as you see your
clock
strike june 2nd it's too late so just
make sure it's in by june 1st all right
that is the that is the cold
hard deadline all right you got to hit
that
i hope that helps you jacob jacob dalton
yo what's up good to see you man
freaking video co-pilot
um rocket league extraordinaire thank
you
for the for the super chat man it means
a lot we're gonna get that rocket league
soon
um i was just freaking it's been busy
it's been busy working on these renders
um
and evolver thanks again man very kind
of you
that's two for one that's that's a
that's an all-time record
um but sweet dude yeah absolutely
absolutely
let's get back to it guys
i'm glad i chose my channel too yeah i'm
glad i chose the channel as well
all right
so the visual or the palinking takes up
a lot of visual weight
and i don't know if i'm happy
with how much weight it actually takes
up and it's actually blocking the
sunlight
from uh the foreground and it'll
probably be blocking the sunlight from
the character itself
like it's kind of on the back here
so i don't know part of me is like torn
with that you know i could just be a
traveler going through this area
yeah a lot to see about that one
i might be able to cheat it and offset
them just a little bit that's a nice
little cheat
so you would take it and push it a
little closer to camera
to let some of that sunlight hit the
character a little bit more
since the you know since the characters
are so stacked up against each other
you can't really tell that it's just off
center a little bit
so i might do that
where do i want to go from here so this
war
probably happened a minute ago
so i definitely want to put some like
grass and shrubs
all up in this robot so we could
probably scatter a few more plants and
whatnot
onto the robot itself
or just maybe around it
but i guess the question would be why
um why would there be larger grass
on the robot versus in the corners of
this thing
so maybe there's just like a few
different pieces of grass and maybe
there's some ivy
going up the walls
hmm there's just like a lot of small
stuff to do on this
i set off your alexa oh no did
everyone's alexa just go off when i said
that
so the white circle right now needs work
back here certainly maybe i'll do a
little bit of that
and it could just be me taking off this
little piece
here let's go into
this guy
and maybe it's just this little piece
here
hmm that's locked up why why is that
locked up
interesting okay it's this instance
maybe if i turn that off
that's a little bit more of that
silhouette
shape
anthony thank you sir for the super chat
what do you think about the render team
system with otoy and render token have
you tried it
um i have not tried it but that's
probably what i'd use if i'm gonna do a
little render farm situation i'm
probably going to do
uh yeah the oh toy
render farm thing um
seems pretty sweet
and it seems a little confusing but i
know andre lebron has a
has a tutorial on how to do that
um
what do we want to do today
have one gig left one gig
of vram left so i should probably use
what
we already have down here as far as
foliage goes i don't want to use
anything else i'll probably get rid of
some of this stuff here that i'm not
using
i don't let's see let's see
i wonder if i hide um
the towers in the background if that'll
save me the vram
so these guys back here skyscraper
it does awesome
sweet so that's the back background
so we can turn these off
just for the time being
and i'll put those in their own folder
that's my background um
background buildings
we got ourselves like two more gigs
that's nice
that's very nice
awesome um yo evolver thanks again for
the super chat you say render is the
cheapest
you've done it hundreds you've done
hundreds with render i'm gonna have to
hit you up about that because i think
that's what i need to do
for this one here absolutely
okay
so let me open up i'm kind of all over
the place today huh
um let's do
vfx materials 3d models cg trader
antennas cranes electric towers
industrial tanks okay let's open up
electric towers
and get these guys up in the scene
because i would like to do a little bit
of electrical tower action
going off into the background
so you probably take all of these
and we can shift drag them into the
scene
shift drag them so they all stack up
into the scene together
and i agree the robot needs more color
variation i think some
black white orange maybe some yellow
i think would be ideal
i have to do this every time dang
nice yeah i found these on cgtrader.com
a bunch of awesome electrical towers
totally worth it freaking
love this kind of stuff it's so cheap
too i think it was like
like 10 bucks or something for all of
these
and i'm just kind of organizing these
in order of height
to see what we can work with
awesome superior productions yo
dude thank you for the super chat
appreciated you saw
on instagram someone's submission they
modeled a velociraptor and rigged it
themselves is that allowed i thought
rig is touchy that is a touchy situation
um i know you're talking about that's
shutter authority
um super good dude i actually know him
personally
um yeah i don't know that's like that
definitely is a tough one
um a lot of people have done
legos they actually did uh like lego
character and obviously a lego character
can't have moved the same way as the
um you know it can't really move the
same way as a human
so that's a bit tricky as well
velociraptor is a little bit tricky
and like some of these humanoid
characters are a little bit tricky
but as long as like it matches the
uh the aesthetic and everything it
i don't know it's it's tough i think it
becomes a little bit more tough when
they are up for like if they're gonna
win or not
then i'm gonna really have to like
figure that out
um if it's up to
a potential winner i'm gonna have to
that's why i have
three other judges i don't want it to be
just me there's too much behind all this
at once you know
um so you know the judges would know all
the rules
and they would say aunt you know can't
really be a thing because they
essentially like messed with the rig
um so yeah we'll we'll have to see on
that one i totally see what you mean
i i know what you mean and i just want
it to be as fair for everyone as
possible so i'm gonna make sure i go
over the rules
make sure the rules are followed um you
know
on these on all of these renders and
whatnot
good question very good question
palinking get out of here
yeah there's a lot of star wars ones too
super cool
mmm okay yeah these are all really cool
looking uh
really cool looking models here
maybe i'll grab this one the tallest one
could be sweet
kind of push this off into the
background a little bit
i'll give it a black texture so i can
see it
and it'll be pretty darn large here
so the idea with this is that i'll have
some ropes and stuff leading off into
the background
to accentuate
that spherical kind of a look
like maybe we'll have something like
back here
and they could just kind of like if i
make an instance of this
they could kind of trail off
into the background
nice
so if we get essentially
a spline going from like
the top of this guy to the corner of
this
building then we can potentially
have a situation where we have a nice
line drawn here
if we need it though i think like i got
to be very sparing with it
definitely um undead hobo
yo what's up dude thank you for the
super chat he says quick question is it
within the rules if the sphere shape is
outlined by a combination of foreground
and mid-ground elements yeah absolutely
that's kind of what i'm doing
that's exactly what that's literally
exactly what i'm doing
um a lot of people have made the sphere
out of um negative space and that's what
you're seeing me do i'm making the
spherical shape out of negative
space um it's just a more creative way
um to do it or just a different way
plain and simple just a different way to
do it
so yeah that's what i'm that's what i'm
doing puffy
dude your render was so good
i think you had the the titanfall one
was that
am i correct on that you had the
titanfall render
holy crap man that was incredible
oh boy yeah that that was a good one
um i think it's on twitter if you guys
look on my twitter
you can see it there it's really nice
oh boy
hmm
um will the other judges make
a render for the montage 2 i don't know
um i doubt it i don't think ren peter or
ian are hiding the fact that they're
doing
renders from me um
but if they were obviously they couldn't
win i obviously can't win
um so yeah it'd be
it'd be fair i wish they were doing
renders for it'd be awesome
william in the house everybody what's
going on
uh william good to see you dude he says
hey everyone just joined um
starting to look really nice yeah dude i
think so
it's uh basically at this point here i
still have work to do
definitely still have some work to do
obviously it's missing the character
but i'm really happy with my environment
the robot needs
um it just has a base coat on it it
needs like more scratches it needs
grunge it needs different colors
probably some orange maybe some yellow
black or white need some birds on it it
needs some
grass growing on it
the little bridge needs work here in the
foreground that needs a little bit more
structure
i need to break it up a little bit i
need to adjust the sphere size in the
background and make sure that that
is like feeling right probably will
choose a different hdri
when it comes down to it to have a
little bit more detail in the clouds
um i'm working on top left
little machine gun nest up there that's
what was shooting down at this robot
perhaps
there's gonna be some cables and wires
going off into the
uh the um
this little like cave essentially or
this tunnel
going off into there um
and then all of the after effects dude
after effects lots of after effects so
i'm going to be doing like
a bunch of different smoke cards and
steam cards
and atmosphere little passes on it
so yeah that's where i'm at right now
uh it looks like you guys have some
other questions too
uh stream the top 100 screening process
too yeah that's exactly what we're doing
next week
for those of y'all who are just joining
next week myself peter france
um ren wykman and ian hubert will be
um judging the top 100 renders and
choosing the five winners from that pool
that'll be next saturday it's gonna be a
big stream
it's gonna be a big one yeah we might
break the
we might break stream records you know
and evolver i know dude how am i gonna
do all this with a gigabyte of vram left
i'm probably gonna have to separate my
foreground and background elements
i think that's the only way to do it
i don't think there's any other way
so i'll probably focus here if i were to
uh let's see here
geometry let's go down to my background
building so i'd probably hide those
to get some vram back and this
building right here i would hide this
guy as well so this would be my mid
ground
let's put that guy into the mid ground
and probably hide that and the render
looks very different
very very different um i'm wondering
if there's a way so i have seven second
seven gigabytes now i'm wondering if
there's a way where i can just like
hide these from
i don't know still have their uh
let's see
give those an octane tag visibility set
to
um so top 100 will only be
reviewed live yes because there's too
many guys we'd have to go through
like a thousand renders that's literally
impossible to do on a live stream that's
gonna take so long it's gonna take us
it's gonna take me the entire week to go
through all these renders
there's just too many of them you know
that's just the way that's just
unfortunately the way it is
uh myself ian wren and peter are going
to go through them all this week
and we're going to choose the top five
and then on saturday we're going to take
the top hundred and go through
now i might do something where like
i somehow show them all i don't know how
i'm going to do that though it's because
like i said the it's going to be about
an hour and a half
if we just play them through it'll be an
hour and a half if we just watch them
and not comment on them
um maybe maybe i'll figure out a way
to do it but right now i don't have any
ideas
i know my mods are up in here they
always help me out with ideas for
streams and stuff so maybe we'll have a
little mod chat
we usually do once a week and we can
figure out a way to maybe do all
thousand ones i don't know it's gonna
have to be a very quick process
i just i don't know how that's gonna go
down
so
okay
yeah let me check how many submissions
we have right now
we are at
4.8 years worth
of collective hours
of work from everybody at least there's
still people who have not submitted
their hours um
733 submissions right now
so far and i'm expecting to hit a
thousand
yeah we'll almost certainly break a
thousand i agree with visual
what are my thoughts on ian's dynamo my
god that's
one of the greatest if not no i'm just
gonna say it it is the greatest
um piece of short film art
on youtube and
freaking unbelievable the visuals are
incredible if you guys know what i'm
talking about just look up ian hubert
dynamo
it's a 20 minute thing he just released
and it is insane it's absolutely
ridiculous
so much work went into that is three
years worth of work he is the best world
builder i know
um yeah
it's crazy this is absolutely insane it
kind of reminds me of a wanker y
movie if you guys know juan karwai he's
a chinese director
and um his movies are very like the
pacing is very slow and it's all about
the vibe
and that's like ian but he's the like
vfx version of one car y
it's insane
and yeah guys visual's right you can um
you can still submit your hours if you
already submitted but didn't type that
in just go back and review the
the um the submission form you can
change
and alter some of the answers being the
hours that you put in
oh snap the musician okay so the
musician who did the music for the
render montage the top 100 montage is
calling me right now
i'll have to hit him back after the
stream he's just wrapping up
the final track it's two tracks put
together actually it's really sweet
i can't wait to show you guys
all right the main drain
floor and the wall but i got all the
scatter stuff going on
corner shrub scatter
let's get a little uh render region
going on here
awesome awesome so i'm trying to find
the right shrubs to
put all around this robot maxset tv
hey man thank you for the super chat
really nice of you
says hey of course you heard about nfts
from people for example and would you
sell
would you like to sell nfts i can help
you with this small percentage i already
sold five
i've sold two so far yes i have sold two
um and this will also be an nft
yeah um i really enjoy it i think it's
super cool
and it's a really nice way it's actually
it was
never part of the plan when i left
corridor
but boy has it helped me stay afloat
yeah certainly has helped me stay afloat
and
given me the opportunity to go off and
create this art full time
so i think it's really cool and it's
only going to get cooler
but thank you for the support i
appreciate you
all right let's see if we can scatter
some plants around this guy
that's gonna be the best way to do this
maybe all right we just cut a little
chunk
out of this so we can do
like a little bit between his legs
and a little bit in front of him
all right so i'll take that piece there
and i'll break it off
with um
let's go back to polygon mode
grab those polygons and we'll do
probably a cut there we'll grab maybe
these polygons
and maybe these ones back up in here
behind him
so it looks like the you know
we're actually growing some trees and
not trees but bushes on this thing so
i'll select those polygons that's what
that's like the surface area where we
want to grow these trees on
bushes plants whatever we hit up break
up
up that's the hotkey for disconnect
u p so now it's its own
little piece right
we can push that under the floor just a
little bit
and we can grow our stuff through that
so that's floor one i'll call this robot
scatter
and we wanna let's see how are we gonna
do this
let's go with
the corner scatter i'll duplicate the
corner scatter
and we'll bring it down in here
i'll call this robot scatter
and we'll change
the plane the surface it's looking for
we'll change that to
robot scatter and if we turn it on
we should have some scattered plants
around
our robot
and we can take the count up maybe to
500.
so we have a lot we have a lot scattered
there
but it's i can't really see it
in the render
so i'll take all those guys and i'm just
going to scale them up
hitting t scale it up
and we have a little bit more shrubbery
around
our robot
um max tv yo thanks again dude
uh he says congratulations with your
sales didn't know about that did you
sell on foundation oversea
um by the way good luck in the future
sales thanks man yeah i sell on
um super rare so if you guys want to see
you know the two pieces
it's super rare dot co slash punisher
that's where i have my uh my crypto art
up
yeah just two pieces right now this will
be the third
sweet that feels pretty nice
like it's very subtle it's definitely up
in there just a couple little patches of
grass and i could probably
take this robot
[Music]
scatter
and maybe pull this out just a little
bit
all right really connect it and then
we'll
push it down on the ground just a little
bit
and i think i'm probably just going to
break up the size of this
so we'll go to the robot scatter
and for scale
let's see how is it doing it with the
ah yes okay so i'm using a noise shader
so i'll copy this
copy shader robot scatter and we'll
paste it so we're adjusting the scale of
these different pieces
different little shrubs here and you can
see that
some are small some are big and if we
adjust the contrast
it'll adjust all that stuff too and
that's just a way to get a little bit
more of
a random dispersion not as much you know
i'm using area lights for my scene
um i'm using a sunlight and i'm using
actually here that's a good question
the main light in my scene is a sunlight
um
i have it hooked up to an uh hdri
environment which is like a gray
the gray sky image that you're seeing
and then um
i have an area light
basically right in front of camera here
it's a large area light boom back here
that's blasting
so i can get a little bit more
reflection off of this mud
the sunlight is doing the work though
from this angle
i'm getting that sunlight blast and i'm
using a bunch of flags
to block a lot of that sunlight
to really shape out the lighting of the
scene and i'm gonna do a full-on
like super stylized breakdown of this
piece of art very similar to the
mortality run piece i did
um and i'm gonna go into how i lit it
how i did everything
um there'll be like a solid 15 minute
video
on how i did everything with this piece
of art in about three weeks all right
guys so definitely don't miss that
so subscribe you know subscribe y'all
that feels good to me on the on the
grass
if we brought out let's see if we
brought out the
robot scatter and we move this
over just a little bit like this maybe
there's a bit more grass
in the scene
just experimenting here with different
different looks
evolver dude are you serious if i sign
the 6k
you'll send the 8k
that's a that's a steal dude if you're
rendering too hard
it might melt off the signature who
knows but i appreciate the super chat
and jones lab too man i appreciate you
too
thank you so much you guys are very kind
so i know i need to texture up this
robot a little bit more
so maybe that's how we'll end the stream
is i'll go in and i'll text up this
robot i'll show you guys my
process just a little bit here
so let me let me try and open that up
let's go mec walker give it a render
hit it with some sunlight
and combine it with
the hdri environment
which i would actually like to change
let's grab one of these
guys
so yeah we got a blue a blue robot and i
went into a lot of this
during my
um let's see how to turn yourself into a
robot video i went over the texturing
the surface imperfections the scratches
the grain grunge
noise all that good stuff and i don't
know if i'll get super into that right
now but
you guys can kind of see that i have i
do have a scratched
surface here and the way i'm doing this
um most of this is already just like
this is a model i got off of cg trader
and it came with the textures but i'm
doing a little extra thing here where
i am using a mixed texture between a
chrome
texture let's actually give that a
little bit of roughness
and the robot texture itself and i'm
breaking that
up with the specular texture it came
with to give me a little bit more
um scratched edges there just to spice
those up a little bit more
now what i want to do is actually give
this robot
different colors throughout his body so
if we do
you know we do a blue version um
we can do a green version maybe
or no let's not do a green version let's
do a yellow
version so if i were to drop
this mixed texture will make a new mix
texture
and let's do here a
hue change the hue to a yellow
it's a greenish saturation i like to
usually max out my saturation
so i can actually see the color i'm like
i'm messing with
it's like an orangish
and this might be like a yellowish color
here
it feels good to me
and i will pipe that
into this new
mix texture boom
and we could just get rid of that
so now we have this new mix texture and
if for whatever reason
your octane textures aren't updating
my face is blocking it right now down
here
but if you double click this little
preview window it'll update it
down below it's a little octane bug
ooh that's cool yeah so i just want like
hints of this
it'd be mostly blue
oh what the heck
bear with me one moment
while i get this texture back
there we go
cool so we want these little certain
parts to be yellow so maybe the
shoulders or something
um let's go into unlit mode so
n d i believe and
c why is this all black
i think it's probably because of the
noise tag
or the normal tag so if you select that
and hit uw
it'll select the entire piece so this
is one piece you guys can see here it's
one giant
mech mesh and the best way
to select the entire piece is to select
one piece from it this is the best way i
know i used to do ui
which is gross selection and i just
mashed this a bunch
but i found out you can actually hit uw
and that will select the entire thing
so u w that's gonna be uh
select connected
is the command is select
connected u w there might be a
an option to select just an entire
piece with one click i don't know of it
but you know boom
select connected and then you can start
dropping on your pieces
so technically since i'm only looking at
it from this one side
um we only really need to texture up
this one side
so i probably do a black version
and i'll do a chromed out version
so like the gun itself maybe will be
like a gun metal
um we could do like a darker version of
this chrome
so we can come into let's go
basic we'll change it to a universal
material we'll give it some metallic
properties
let's see
we want let's see i wanted to be a
darker chrome
essentially maybe we go back to glossy
the index we take pretty far up diffuse
comes down to zero so it's black
and the more we bring the index down the
darker that gets
and we can bring the roughness way up
and the index down a little bit more
and like this is kind of like your
gunmetal
texture here which you can just
select oh uf is that the one
uf fill selection
uh uw i like is better because it
doesn't you don't have to click
or actually wait oh it's the whole thing
yes
uf that's a good one i like that
so i'm going through and just selecting
all these pieces so that'll be like our
gunmetal
it's like a giant arm these are pincers
so these pincers can just be like
titanium
pincers
and i'll go through this and just kind
of give it a little bit more
ram just like randomly deciding what
color these should be
so if these are like chromed out
and i feel like we don't need to go too
ham on the surface imperfections just
because
you know this robots me far away
maybe these guys can be
crummed out
and it's really just have fun with it
you know
maybe the head could be white
so you can actually tell it's the head
and instead of yellow maybe we go for
like an orange or something
so i know this one actually wants to be
black
i'll take the saturation down to zero
brightness to one
and it'll be like a dark gray yeah we
can take the gamma to like 1.2
and darken it up a little bit we'll copy
that mix material
and replace it with the new one here
boom so now we have a black one and then
we said we wanted to do
hmm why they go white
oh yeah we wanted to do a bit more of an
orange
so if we do this here let's go back to
that hue and saturation
what the heck why is it why is it doing
this
uh i guess it deletes
so strange
anyway i'll just i'll keep things easy
right now let's stick to this
one thing at a time i'm all over the
place
yeah i think it looks a little cooler
and yeah i'll just hit these like main
panels
with these colors here which looks nice
oh maybe those are blue
and like these guys here can probably be
a
maybe the gunmetal
maybe the head is gunmetal too kind of
like that a little bit nicer
same for all these pistons and pipes
these can be chromed out
in here
and these guys
let's have that be
orange
kind of cool this piece
can probably be that darker color so let
me
try this one more time um let's bring
this out
bring out the mix material
we'll darken this up saturation zero
brightness one gamma 1.2
yes and we'll apply that to this mixed
material
i'm not going to delete it this time i'm
just going to replace it
and we'll drop that on there
sweet we can darken it up even more
brightness point five
maybe even point two
awesome and we can kind of just fill in
like the darker areas with
that black metal
to essentially what you're doing is like
just accenting certain pieces
so the more like core parts of the robot
can be that dark metal color
and i'm really not worrying about the
other side because i'm only seeing this
robot from one side
nice
oh the missile pods that's super cool
those could probably be the chromed out
bits and this could literally be
whatever
color you want any style you choose
these this little backpack jetpack
situation could be mostly
black
and the backpack piece can be chromed
out
or maybe the gunmetal
and the antennas for sure will be darker
nice okay the feet can probably be
darker as well
and yeah this this is the process you
know
it's just the process
let's see what this actually does here
let's see what this looks like
okay so i'm gonna copy this
oh i actually wonder if i can just copy
all of this stuff
and paste it onto the existing robot to
get the color
let's see if that works
all right so it brings in a new mesh
and i'm wondering let's see if i take
all this and
drop it on to the existing one
if that will actually work i hope so
it should in theory that should
definitely work
let's give it a render and see what
happens
well that goes i'll answer any questions
you guys have i think that's
uh probably going to be it for me today
um you know i'm taking a little break
here come back
keep working on my render and keep
plucking away at these details thank you
guys for
for joining me um and if you don't know
already by this point next week
is the live stream where myself ian
hubert
peter france and ren weichmann all get
together and
we are gonna go over at least the top
100 renders to choose the top five
winners
we'll see what we can do we're going to
have at least 1 000
submissions right now there's 733 with
about
just under five years worth of total
collective
hours worth of work between all of you
guys that's a lot
that's a lot so we're gonna do our best
to go over
as much as we can without you know
having it be a 12-hour stream
all right we want to keep it under four
hours
if we can absolutely
um let's see all right so questions on
the stream post the circle is not
very circle are you going to adjust that
yes i'm going to adjust that
i'll make it more of a circle um did i
model the robot no i got the robot from
cg trader that is my
favorite website for um for 3d models
cg trader the what the prices are
actually very affordable
and reasonable turbo squid can get a
little pricey
but you know it's actually
it's not that bad because or it's not
that unreasonable because
i understand why you would want to
charge a lot of money for all the hard
work that you have put in
so yeah that makes sense
hmm i should learn quicksilver mixer
really easy and really fast way to
texture and can literally drag in two
megascans textures and they will be
it will blend perfectly i do need to
learn quiksil
mixer um i use qixel
enough to be able to justify that so i
think that's a good idea
should probably get on that
um what was my render time well i'm
doing low res
low sample renders that take probably a
couple hours
but my 4k full res full sample
render will probably take 20 to 30
40 minutes per frame and i have an extra
150 frames in my render so it's 300
so it'll be a lot it'll be a lot
where do i stand on an oreo cookie are
you the guy who did the oreo render
because the guy who did that oreo render
would ask that question
i like me good i like me a good oreo i
don't buy them but if they're around
i'll have me in oreo
what software would i recommend for
creating sprawling landscapes
um i recently got into a program called
uh world creator and it is unbelievable
i'm using it for a render that i'm
working on that you guys hadn't seen
anything yet it's just like a low-key
backseat render
i'm working on that one i use world
creator and it's really cool it lets you
shape the landscape and use filters to
like
get the most realistic looking
environments possible it's crazy
i used it for this too with the whole
but i eventually took that hole out
um necco why do i have an extra 150
frames in my
render well that's because my um
my render is going to be kicking off the
render montage videos it'll also be
ending it
so what i want to do is create a tone
create a vibe
i'm going to do some sound design for my
piece and get people like
seated down looking at something really
cool and then it's going to cut to all
of your guys's
so that's why why mine is a little bit
longer is so that um
it essentially sets the tone and it sets
the vibe and i need a little bit more
time to do that i did it with the last
render challenge as well
i made it i think a little bit longer
and i slowed it down a little bit
but you guys definitely
without question needs to be 150 frames
30 frames per second
do you think we can hit a thousand
submissions i absolutely do think we can
hit a thousand submissions
what else we got what else we got y'all
any other questions
yeah that's a good one um thank you guys
for joining me
um downloading a model or creating from
xero what do you recommend for beginners
uh it depends on what you want to learn
guys
i have learned a whole bunch by creating
models
from scratch
i've also learned a whole lot
downloading models
and placing those models in my scene
like that's that's
you'll learn a lot more on composition
you're not trying to
i like the way blender guru said it he's
like if you modeled
the book stand and the in the
the books and the coffee table and
everything like in all the little
details
you'll certainly feel a lot more
satisfaction in your final result
because you've done everything from
scratch it'll take a lot longer
but what blender guru is saying is that
you are trying to present
a arc viz style render you're trying to
present an environment
all right and just because um
you know if you modeled everything from
scratch that's amazing
but i don't think there's like an issue
with downloading assets the assets are
there for a reason
uh for you to download and for you to
use people make assets for a reason
because they know that people don't have
all the time in the world now if you're
making a video game
there are some times where you can
download the
assets for games other times it might be
something you create from scratch as
well
it just depends depends on the situation
if you're beginner
wanting to learn how to model then
certainly model your own stuff if you're
a beginner trying to create
interesting landscapes then
make as many interesting landscapes as
you can
you want to iterate and you want to you
want to get through as many
interesting landscapes as possible you
want to do it as many times as possible
because you're going to learn through
that experience
and if you're sitting here like doing
one environment every year
because you modeled everything you're
going to learn a whole lot
i promise you but if you want to really
like
make your education as
potent as possible to specifically
working on environments then you need to
just be creating environments constantly
so it's it just depends it certainly
just depends
um while i do a stream with people maybe
one day maybe one day
but not in the near future
[Music]
how many submissions were there last
time there were 125 submissions last
time
this time last i checked like 20 minutes
ago there are 733
so there's going to be probably a
thousand submissions
and it's going to be awesome
the final montage video is going to be
huge
and probably an hour and a half long
will everyone be included in that render
montage um
yes everyone will be included
in one giant hour and a half long render
montage but i'm also going to be doing
a top 100 render montage as well so
there's going to be both
so just depends on how much time you
have you want to
watch 100 uh you know an hour and a half
long thing
absolutely put it on at a party put it
on the background put it up on the big
screen and let it play you know while
you work get inspired
that'll that'll definitely be for that
i'm gonna have music going for it
custom music um not custom music but uh
specifically i'm going to choose music
that fits the tempo
of the renders the top 100 montage
will have custom music written for it
it's actually already finished
so i can't wait for you to guys hear
that in two weeks
where do you submit if you uh go to the
discord to go to the info channel
on the discord you'll see where to
submit
how do i select certain things as if
it's a group of polys
um you can select the polygon and hit u
w or you can hit uf and use that tool
to select chunks basically little parts
what's my dream project
what's my dream project to work on
something
that i am extremely passionate about
with my friends and family
that is the dream project um
whatever the story may be as long as as
long as i'm super passionate about it
and my friends and family who are
working on that with me together are
super passionate about it then it's
gonna be the best thing ever
i know that for a fact
hassan i'm not gonna play music in the
stream i'm leaving that to you
you can play whatever music you want
over top my voice right now
um i think the vibe would get a little
repetitive if i played music
on the stream but i have not
uh i've gotten that request a lot
certainly so guys
i appreciate you very much um thanks for
hanging out with me
if you guys want to get some internet
security for yourself check out nordvpn
you know they're down in the description
they help me out on this stream today
made this one possible
um if you guys click that link down
there it's gonna help me out it's gonna
help me do more of these and it's gonna
help me do this stuff full time
and that's why i left corridor is to do
this stuff full time so check them out
nordvpn they're legit
you know you can change your server to
europe and watch all the ghibli movies
on netflix
uh you can switch it to japan to watch a
bunch of cool anime on netflix and
it's a good time it's really cool so
check them out helps me out guys i
appreciate you very much
you guys have a solid day have a good
weekend be safe oh it's all my indian
audience if you're still awake i know
it's late for you guys
hope you guys are safe stay well um and
same same to you guys
definitely stay safe
enjoy the weekend enjoy the
remaining days you guys have to get
these renders in
i'm gonna enjoy mine i know that it's
gonna be really cool june 1st
59 pm pacific standard time is the
deadline
as soon as the clock hits june 2nd it's
too late
all right guys thank you so much next
week
is a super stream the super like mark
your calendars right now subscribe to
this channel right now if you're not
already
ian hubert peter france ren wykman
and myself review your art live
on the stream next saturday and we're
going to choose the top five winners
we're going to win some insane prizes
we're going to go over everything um
next saturday 10 45 a.m pst
same time same place you guys know how
to do it
but thank you guys thank you all i
appreciate you guys
and uh have a good one
good luck guys peace
[Music]
two
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you